food lovers from coast-to-coast have
saver you thresholds restaurant reviews
and culinary insights for nearly 50
years the trailblazing food writer first
made a name for herself working at the
Los Angeles Times before taking her
expertise east to the New York Times
Rachel took over as editor-in-chief of
Gourmet magazine in 1999 in her new book
save me the plums my gourmet memoir
rachel opens up about her decade running
gourmet good morning good morning I know
it took you a long time to figure out
what you wanted to write in this book
what happened when you started and you
sat down writing well at first I thought
I wanted to write a really breezy book I
mean it was like for me it was a
Cinderella story right I was an ordinary
person took the subway to work worried
about money and suddenly I am in this
lala land of drivers and a clothing
allowance and hair and makeup people and
you know I a magazine editor and a
magazine and it was editor in chief
editor now yes and I thought I was going
to write the Cinderella's story and
about all the colorful characters at
Conde Nast and as I got deeper into it I
thought I really want this book to be
useful to people and so let me really
talk about what it feels like to learn
to be a leader you know I mean I had
never met I mean Here I am I'm a writer
right I sit in my little cubicle and
suddenly I've got 65 people who work for
me including one of your employees it
says do you know what you're doing he
says do you know what you're doing with
such disdain and I didn't yeah and the
staff knew that I didn't know I mean you
know the ordinary language of magazines
was like Martian to me I mean they used
words that I have no idea what it's
about so Ruth what was the skill because
writers are solitary people so how what
was the key for you the key for me was
suddenly realizing I don't know
everything and I'm going to hire people
who are smarter than I am and let them
have their head yeah
that for me the key to management is
fine people are really good and trust
them and that your job is to run
interference for them yeah I mean it's
funny that at one point somebody told
you that you're you're you're actually
too accessible but you know what I think
is interesting is your journey as a
person at eight years old you see a
gourmet magazine there's a swordfish on
it and you see that magazine and it just
sparks something in you and I wonder
what that was because you never thought
that eating food writing about food
could be a living you just saw it as a
hobby what did you see as a little kid
it was an extraordinary story by a
really great writer from the forties
actually eight though I was eight but I
read it and I suddenly saw that food
could be a magic door that everything
I'd ever read was fairytales you know
there was always like some kind of magic
thing that happened and in this story
suddenly everyday objects are wondrous
and I suddenly saw oh if I pay attention
to what I'm eating I can have
extraordinary experiences here on earth
it doesn't have to be fiction and from
that moment on my life changed where I
really saw that paying attention to
ordinary things was a way to have a
great life everybody takes pictures of
their food now you think it's a good
idea in less than ten seconds I don't I
think you should eat it you should enjoy
it you should be in the moment instead
of many taking a picture of it you're
distancing it no food is all about love
and really gathering around in
restaurants you've you've reminded us of
that thank you so much this book is
called save me the plums there's a
backstory on that it's on sale today
wherever you like to buy your books